[Music]
so as Hillary continues her 2017 woman
scorned tour serious allegations
continue to emerge about an overbearing
creepy Democratic leader who harasses
women but enough about her husband
boop-boop today it's Harvey Weinstein
who Hillary finally addresses I was just
sick I was shocked I was appalled it was
something that was just intolerable in
every way and you know like so many
people have come forward and spoken out
this was a different side of a person
who I and many others had known in the
past excellent software but a little
late don't you think
some are hammering her for waiting so
long but can you blame her first
Harvey's a friend I mean wouldn't you
have called him a friend would you have
called him a friend yes I probably would
have and and so with so many others you
know people in democratic politics for a
couple of decades appreciated his help
and support yes he poured money into
campaigns campaigns that offered him the
ideal cover for his deplorable behavior
every Pig gets a pass when your
progressive by the way I love how
Hillary says she'll donate the money she
got from Harvey that's just
recirculating the cash why not just give
the money back would you give the money
back well there's no one to give it back
to what other people are saying what my
former colleagues are saying is they're
going to donate it to charity and of
course I will do that she can't give the
money back yes you can you write the
check to Harvey Weinstein and you send
it to him I suspect she knows where to
find him I also suspect he'll need the
money soon second it's hard for Hilary
to condemn a CAD which he stood by one
for so long in a way she's the
personification of Hollywood it's hard
to speak out when you've tolerated such
crap for decades remember the women who
came out about Bill they were dismissed
by you-know-who Hilary's not much
different from those Hollywood a-listers
who knew
for years and traded sordid details like
baseball cards and that's the point this
was not Harvey's secret this was
Hollywood secret he was brazen about it
he never tried to hide it he just
assumed his politics and his power had
him covered and man he was right for a
while I have a theory Jesse and it might
have been your theory because I think I
stole it from you that if Hillary had
been elected president this story might
not have broken because they would have
been able to stop the New York Times
from running it because he was a friend
is that a crazy theory well if it was my
theory it's definitely crazy
self-awareness listen if she's so sick
and appalled by this why'd she wait a
week to say anything she also jumped the
gun on you said yesterday the Vegas
shooting right away the Trump birth
control order she spoke out right away
the Hurricanes the Barcelona terror
attack the first day she came out with
this
she wasn't shocked because to her it
wasn't a revelation it was an open
secret and Hillary's all too familiar
with open secrets also why she didn't
react right away no reporters asked her
when there's a Republican scandal every
Republican in Congress has reporters
outside their door asking no one even
knocked on her door
no one wants her to say anything because
it's going to hurt the party so you have
Bill Clinton you have Anthony Weiner and
now Harvey Weinstein all of these really
inappropriate men in Hillary's orbit I
almost feel sorry for and then I was
thinking how did she treat the women
that were Bill's mistresses or victims
of bills alleged sexual misconduct she
orchestrated smear campaigns there was
intimidation there were settlements so
Hillary likes to say she wants to clean
up Wall Street and police and regulate
Wall Street how about she tries to clean
up in police Hollywood because the
casting couch culture is criminal in
Hollywood and we can see this there's
this one guy a dozen victims there's
probably two dozen victims this is
running rampant there if she's a real
feminist
and a real true icon who stands up for
women's rights you don't
just move money around and send this
check to Planned Parenthood or to
Emily's list you know what you do you
hold the summit you set up a hotline you
talk to the victims you give a major
speech in Hollywood and you try to
correct the culture she's not doing that
though and she'd earned herself a lot of
respect and a lot of credibility in the
way that her husband did with the sister
souljah movement or you know Nixon goes
to China if she went to her own backyard
and started actually standing up for
women's rights even I would say Hillary
you're doing the right thing Jesse
Watters uber feminists there's Harvey
talking to some reporters it's pretty
interesting you know what I love Dana he
uses lingo like second chance it's like
it's like I think he is befuddled by all
the attention because it had been
accepted for so long it's like hey wait
a second I'm Harvey this is what Harvey
did I used to open the door with my
bathrobe open don't you know that well I
find that whole I knew all of a sudden
he realizes he needs help yes a sexual
addiction clinic to be like oh really
like all of a sudden because his play he
had a ploy in order to say I'll dedicate
all my time to the NRA yeah hoping that
that would basically get him thank you
help me Rogers it could be fired NYPD is
investigating two cases yeah absolutely
the Scotland Yard is also looking at at
a case as well just thought I'd throw
that fact one more question
Barbie white she never contacted you you
know I was asked that today I think it's
a pertinent question
I know his brother hit on a good friend
of mine it was very disgusting okay so
you have the story not me I'm sorry to
hear that
look I think that he's trying to
engender some public sympathy for
himself because guess what I do think
that there are criminal prosecutions
that are being looked at very seriously
especially given the
burr of alleged victims and people that
have come forward to say not just
horrific harassment but sexual
misconduct the sexual assault or a
sexual battery so as a variety of
charges now in a case like this what I
would do to try to preserve the secrecy
of it if I was a prosecutor I didn't
panel a grand jury to bait to listen to
the evidence to hear some witnesses go
for it and in a grand jury the target of
the grand jury which in this case would
be mr. Weinstein would be able to
proffer evidence on his behalf that is
exculpatory should he choose to do so
his counsel with the pride of the
opportunity to do that so that's what I
think some of the things and the
discussions you know behind the scenes
that are going on right now but it's not
you know just New York and Scotland Yard
it's also Los Angeles District
Attorney's Office as well so you see
there's a number of jurisdictional
issues which I find to be legally
fascinating you know Juan Weinstein who
was one of the early supporters of Roman
Polanski and I'm sure he's thinking like
you had Meryl Streep giving you know a
standing out at Roman Polanski he is
living in an in a lucid dream where all
this stuff is somehow okay and now he's
waking up and he's realizing why why are
they turning on me what was really
interesting point because we just saw
him on video they are waving at people
who's getting into that SUV so the two
stories to tell about that one is the
police were called because of some kind
of problem at his daughter's home you
know the wife has left him and
apparently got into an argument with the
daughter and we don't know the details
of it but apparently the police as I
said were called to the house checked
out
she was seidel thoughts well we don't
know that we know that could be a spin
in terms of trying to garner sympathy
for him but the second part of it that
fascinated me along the lines of what
you were saying is so he then turns to
the paparazzi and says hey you guys you
know me yes i I've always been good to
you guys but then you know Democratic
politicians I've been given you my or
hate media I helped you get access to
some of these stars of kete key moments
and so that's the way I thought that's a
revealing moment for her Harvey
Weinstein's mine that he thinks evil
with paparazzi who are getting in your
face when the world is
grumbling on you that he can say here's
here's how I deal with you here's how I
make my appeal but now let me just come
back to your pillow right yeah which is
to say you know what I think that this
is about bad behavior by males who like
sex generally across all party lines but
especially by politically powerful men
or corporate powerful men or men with
money I think that this is the excess
that they think they can get away that
it becomes their prerogative to do what
they want to do and if you have women
who have ambitions who are willing to
come up to the hotel room they think
they can get away with it and he got
away with it and it's criminal but to
make fun of Hillary Clinton I just don't
see it by the way this is her this she
has a problem with her husband who
crossed many lines and so she has the
personal issue I think lots of women you
know we're like saying hey you know what
what is that famous country music song
stand by your man right so but that's a
personal issue and I would stay away
from it policy issues gun control you
know let me get this Hollywood has spent
most of their lives judging our behavior
we are a moral if we if we if our
climate footprint is too large if we
voted for Trump were deplorable they
make they make politics personal you saw
Eminem for example basically say if
you're a fan of Trump I don't want you
listening to my music right there are
actors who say if you voted for Trump I
don't want you watching my movies they
hold more pate for Trump than they do
for Isis no wait a second so what do you
I don't get your put so what they say we
disagree they're using their platform as
celebrities in America celebrity soap
culture to say what they think right and
you don't like it because you're
libertarian or conservative right okay
but I don't see that that then says to
us or to conservatives oh delight in the
fact that Harvey Weinstein was a
Democratic donor I'd say hey they
delight they did to MIT Romney MIT
Romney had a binder full of women they
demonize I don't think they mocked him
priest was saying he had a binder full
of
what do you guys say then about trucks
should everybody on the Republican side
send their money back to Trump no
hypocrisy is and this is to Hillary
Clinton's point when Bill was having
some problems with a lot of different
women Hillary didn't believe any of them
correctly we're all out for this but
when all these women come forward with
Harvey Weinstein she believes every 16
she believes every single one of them
and Harvey's a bad guy so you know
either women are to be believed or
they're not I know Hillary changed her
you're my daughter
you're much younger and better-looking
than I am but let me just thank you you
don't have to go any further but let me
just tell you you know I say this with
with heart feelings women oftentimes
defend their husbands and try to keep
their families together and we'll go to
extreme that's a personal chef Jesse did
not she left her husband immediately
gonna have to make I'm just saying the
way Hillary conducted herself changed
depending on the policy tremendous
pressure here because everybody was
coming after and I was being talked
about on every show and you gotta call
it out and she took her time yeah the
night night comedians that you guys love
to you know mock they made so much fun
of Bill Clinton oh my god nothing about
this guy just other thing I I'm
convinced that we're hearing about the
actresses who generally have more power
than a lot of women in Hollywood what
about the pas the caterers the gaffers
the hair and makeup people who who can't
say anything because they will be fired
well and they probably don't have the
networks that would allow you to be able
to walk away from a job yeah I think
that's actually the ongoing legal
problems are going to be huge I think
the board members are gonna have to
answer to for a lot of this because if
it was such an open secret and the
payoffs were happening three years ago
and they knew about it then it's
possible that they too would be liable
illegally yeah all right I'm banning
open secret because it makes no sense if
it's an open secret it's not a secret is
it
I don't know lifetime ban a lifetime ban